[Music]
[Applause]
spring and albert breer the monday
morning quarterback senior nfl reporter
joining us from the nfl meetings i don't
know if that's big news down there that
taysom hill is the quarterback
experiment is over now that sean payton
is not in new orleans and now he's going
to focus on being a tight end it's an
expensive tight end they have
yeah but i think the quarterback
experiment was over when you look at the
structure of the contract that he did
yeah and you saw like how the numbers
jump to like quarterback like real
quarterback numbers if he's actually
playing quarterback so like once you saw
that contract it's like
they're not playing him at quarterback
anymore because they weren't going to
pay the freight especially with all the
the cap issues that they have all right
i wanted to talk to you have you on
because of the overtime rule the
proposals that are going on where are we
right now and
you know when do they vote on these
proposals or a singular proposal
i i think the the meeting the
competition committee meeting is from 10
30 to 11 30 so like the vote will come
relatively soon i think we'll get it you
know well before noon um and like
talking to a couple informed people
last night it sounds to me like 50 50.
like 50
it gets tabled and they talk about it
again in may
um you know and and i think there's like
a 25 chance maybe it's oh it's for
playoffs only 25
it's for
everything and so
you know part of the issue here dan and
a lot of people haven't talked about
this but there's a third proposal that's
come up now so you know what the
indianapolis philadelphia proposal is
where a guarantee of possession for each
team the tennessee proposal where you
can only end it if you have the first
possession if you go for two
the third proposal is really interesting
it was initially called continuation i
think now they've started to call it
extended period roger goodell troy
vincent this has been talked about at
the highest levels of the league over
the last couple of days quietly they're
going to bring it up in the competition
committee meeting
the idea would be the game just continue
so if you have the ball into the fourth
quarter like it's almost like instead of
going from first half to second half
you're going from third quarter fourth
quarter again where you flip the field
but the team that has the ball keeps the
ball and so then you go into sudden
death it takes the coin toss out of it
it means the possession that you have in
overtime is an earned possession it's
not a random thing
and it mitigates the issue with the
quarterbacks and i think the main thing
here is the overtime rule change they
made 10 12 years ago was because the
kickers were too good right the reason
they're doing it the reason this over
time things come up again is because the
quarterbacks are too good and so i think
that there's a concern like where does
that end you know what i mean like are
we gonna be back here five or ten years
from now talking about something else
whereas if you went to the continuation
model you take the coin toss out of it
you make the possession earned whoever
has the ball has the ball so
i like i'll be honest with you like this
came onto my radar over the weekend so i
don't haven't had like all this time to
workshop and i think a lot of people are
like that i don't vote on continuation
today but i think it's possible that
that third idea is intriguing enough or
they say okay like let's table this till
may so everybody can have an idea or
everybody can have a chance to think
about this third idea for a couple of
months
uh is there more of a market for jimmy
garoppolo or baker mayfield
i would say there are more teams that
would be
[Music]
willing to go with jimmy garoppolo as
their starting quarterback right now i
think the issues the two guys are
separate
i think there are teams that would roll
the dice on baker and say okay look if
you're seattle like maybe i'd bring in
baker to come and compete with drew
locke
but i'm not going to do it at 18.58
million dollars and so baker i think
it's purely the money and there's not a
team out there that's willing to lock
him in as their starting quarterback and
if you're not willing to lock a guy in
as you're starting quarterback you're
not going to pay him
18.858 million dollars so
i think ultimately maybe this comes down
to cleveland eating some of the contract
and taking some of the money on
and then trading him for whatever day
three draft pick
whereas with jimmy it's about the
shoulder
this is jimmy this is the last year
jimmy's contract and so if you're
trading for him you're trading for him
for right now but that's the only reason
you're trading for him and if jimmy's
not going to throw
until the end of june beginning of july
that means you've got no spring work
right and while they think he's going to
be okay coming back
like in august and september you don't
know that so
if you bring him in for one year and you
have doubts about maybe where he'll be
in september october maybe feel good
he'll be there in november well then
that mitigates that one-year benefit
that you're getting for having him on
the roster and oh by the way he already
missed the spring he's going to come in
a little bit behind in training camp
anyway and so i think the uncertainty
with the shoulder is the biggest issue
in moving garoppolo and the niners at
one point thought they were going to be
able to get a couple of second round
picks for him whereas with mayfield i
think it's the fact that nobody be
willing to take them on as like their
lock stock and barrel starter which
makes the money a problem well that's
what i wondered about garoppolo that
they were entertaining the idea of
getting two second round picks for him
but that does that mean trey lance is
ready to go next season as your starter
yeah so
i think where they are on trey
they like him a lot like and if you look
like his trajectory last year
was
he would look raw when they first got
him
they got to the summer there's a 40 day
days off that they have between june and
july he comes back and like incredible
like improvement right so if you
remember the first 10 days of camp there
was like a real question like could he
come and take the job from jimmy and
then he leveled off and he didn't play
very well when he got his first chance
to play like week four or five whatever
it was the tape wasn't good but then
towards the end of the year he started
to ascend again i think where they are
on trey right now
they could play him but kyle can't run
his convent like the conventional kyle
shanahan offense yet with him and he'd
have to game it up a little bit now we
know we remember what that looked like
when he had robert griffin in washington
all those years ago i think he feels
like he could do that ideally do they
want to do that
i mean if jimmy's still around that
maybe that be that question whereas if
jimmy's gone i think they're you know
they go all in on a different type of
offense for right now to make it work
for traylands in the short term while he
grows as a quarterback he's albert brier
senior nfl reporter monday morning
quarterback joining us from the nfl
meetings
i know that the dolphin said it was fake
news about
tom brady and tom brady wanting to go
there
rumors out of boston that they were in
discussions there
anything
with any morsels of that true
i think it was a discussion point
but i think for the dolphins but i think
it was a discussion point
before mike mcdaniel became the coach so
i think that's sort of where the divide
is
and
i do know this like the owner after
coming out of the watson thing in the
fall
i think the owner really decided okay
like
we have this advantage with a
quarterback on a rookie contract i want
to find out about tula and i want to get
an answer onto it i think that's part of
why they trade for tyree kill and they
signed toronto armstead it's like take
all the excuses away like let's find out
what we have because after three years
based on the way rookie contracts are
set up in the nfl that's when you got to
make your decision on a young
quarterback i mean you see the tension
between kyle and murray and the
cardinals right now
that's the juncture contractually that
the dolphins are going to be at with two
of next year so i think the owner really
kind of wanted to see on tua
but the possibility of brady the tie to
flores all that different stuff i think
that was sort of something that had been
a thought in that organization for a
while i don't think it really is anymore
and i think part of it for brady too i
mean look he had like that i don't even
want to call it retirement like it's
like a five to six week cooling off
period so you can think about things
right and like i think part of the whole
process for brady personally was coming
to terms with
if i'm gonna play in 2022 it's gonna
have to be in tampa
and then the reason he came back when he
came back on march 10
was because he knew
to get guys back and all the free agents
they had to get those guys back it would
have to be
then otherwise he'd risk coming back to
a shell of the team that he played with
the last couple of years explain the
expansion of the rooney rule
so there are a couple of different
things there um there's the requirement
um that
they bring in
and like that every team brings in
like either a diverse or a female
a candidate or a coach assistant coach
that works on the offensive side that
coach is going to have you know a direct
line to the head coach there are going
to be sort of things built in to
like define the role of that person the
idea being that that person could
eventually grow into becoming a
quarterbacks person which is where the
real pipeline is and we've seen this
over the last few years intensify
like that
they're going to get more diversity in
the quarterback coaching pipeline so
that's the idea there they added women
to the rooney world the definition of
the rooney rule
and we'll see how that plays out i don't
think we're there yet but maybe you know
five ten years from now that becomes
more of a
like a realistic piece of of the
discussion
you know and and then i think one of the
biggest things dan is like what they're
talking about doing outside of it
which is
if you talk to like black assistant
coaches who've interviewed for jobs i'm
telling you the number one complaint and
i i guess it's an easy number one is
i'll interview i think it went well and
then the owner will tell me he was more
comfortable with this guy over here it's
like well what does that mean and what
these guys are saying is you need to get
us in front of the owners right and so i
think for the first time i you know
hearing them say yesterday we need to
get
young assistant coaches young scouts in
front of the owners in social settings
in non-interview settings do at the
combine doing it at the owner's meetings
that's really important so
maybe in some cases a guy's interviewing
for a job and it's not the first time
that he's met that owner if the comfort
level thing is a problem then that's the
only way to fix it as i see it anyway
the worst dressed head coach there at
the nfl meeting suzu
you're gonna get me in trouble here huh
uh i know matt roll took a beating on
twitter uh yesterday right like so
whose pants were was he wearing because
they looked like they they were a foot
too long they were a little too long
like that's like i mean i i when i saw
his pants and i loved that but when i
saw his pants i sort of thought to
myself like
that's like when you like
when you're on a trip and you like dump
wine on your pants or something like
that and you've got to go to like the
outlet store and just pick up whatever
you can get right yeah it felt like one
of those situations for me um
i don't know who the worst dressed to be
like i said you're gonna get me in
trouble here dan um
well mike mccarthy's not here he might
have been a candidate andy reid you
could make an argument both ways right
like some people would say he's the
worst dress other people would say he's
the best
where are you at on that um
he's got the the luelle collection that
that he seems to have
trademarked there and belichick's not
there right
well bill's here oh he is oh bill he
didn't show up for the picture
yeah he actually the story was that he
and matt patricia were hustling towards
the uh towards the the the front of the
hotel which is where the picture was
taking
and they were hustling towards the front
of the hotel and they didn't quite make
it so i'm sure he was heartbroken that
he couldn't be in the picture
but but he has a very bill has bill has
a bill bill's head of bills at these
meetings bill's a very
nantucket golfer look if that makes
sense like kind of pastels maybe some
white shorts and like a golf visor yeah
that's because of his uh wife or his
girlfriend
she yeah yeah oh she definitely has a
hand in the wardrobe no question
absolutely yeah are you reporting that
yes okay yes i think i think i can
safely report that uh any other rule
changes that we need to be aware of
because it feels like sometimes these
things sneak up on us and we go wait
when did that happen and somebody go go
that was in march
no i mean like there's so there's so
there's a rule that was experimental
with the onside kick i won't bore you
with the details but it was like a
health and safety thing that they're
gonna you know move from temporary to
permanent i think that's sort of a
formality
um you know the rooney rule stuff was
important this is like what's
interesting is like
outside of like the overtime thing there
weren't rules changes and normally
you'll have like six or seven things and
some will go through and some won't
i actually like talking to coaches like
that's a positive thing that means like
the rules are maybe in a decent place
and i think that should help the
officiating too i mean look the
officials have taken a beating the last
few years and in some cases rightfully
so
i mean you've been on the field for an
nfl game i don't know how anybody makes
heads heads or tails a field level of
what's going on and so i've always
thought about like how those guys have
to train their eyes to see things and if
you're training your eyes to see things
and then you've got to like process five
changes six changes to the rules every
year like how difficult that would be
i wonder if the rules are stagnant for a
couple years if officiating would
improve and i certainly know like the
coaches like the fact that they don't
have to go back to their players now and
say yeah these five or six things you
got to do them differently are you the
most famous person in that room right
now
um
no comment
[Laughter]
well i don't want to tell i don't want
to sound like a jerk but i might be
right now because the coaches are in
meetings
so there might be some nfl reporters in
there but you're more famous i'm very
hot i'm i'm i'm very humble
i don't want to don't talk about myself
that way man okay uh i won't tell peter
king you said that uh albert great great
to talk to you thanks for joining us as
always
awesome thanks dan that's albert brier
from the nfl meetings